All right, pop quiz, Andy, where's that going to be?
>> I'm going to click Related Lists over here
and then drag down Open Activities and Activity History.
>> Just for good measure, I mean, once you close tasks it'll start showing up
in the Activity History instead of Open
Activities, so good to have it all there.
>> Sure. Now I'm going to Save and not forget
to Save. Cool, and there's our new maintenance ticket.
>> Awesome. Assigned to you.
>> Yeah.
>> Due today.
Not started yet.
>> So if I were a user and I wanted to find my tickets, how would I do that?
>> Yeah, you can see all your open tasks straight from the home tab.
>> Okay, so home.
>> So, at the bottom of the home
tab, there's this calendar, and it talks about
all of the events or meetings that could
be coming up. Right there. There's your open task.
>> Very cool. Okay, and if I, oh, I don't even need to, to
click on it. I hover and it tells me the subject, the due date, priority
and that kind of stuff.
>> Yeah, and you can even mark it as complete right there.
>> Oh, cool, but I won't, because I haven't yet.
>> Mm-hm.